lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
hablar un poco sobre espectrofotometría
suena muy sofisticado está basada en un
principio muy simple si tengo supongamos
que tenemos dos soluciones que contienen
algún tipo de solutos
esta es la solución 1 y esta es la 2
supongamos que estas celdas son del
mismo tamaño esta es la solución número
1 y esta es la número 2 ahora supongamos
que la solución número 1 tiene una menor
cantidad de soluto esta es la línea del
agua
y vamos a ponerlo de color amarillo este
tiene poco soluto mejor los hombre haré
si tiene menos quedaría algo así y
supongamos que la solución 2 tiene más
absoluto
pondré muchas líneas expresando eso la
concentración del soluto es más alta
aquí
alte
concentración
alta concentración
y esta es la baja
baja
con seny
baja concentración
baja concentración de solutos qué
pasaría si hacemos incidir un poco de
luz a través de estas celdas supongamos
que la luz que incidimos está a una
longitud de onda específica que es
sensible al soluto que hemos disuelto
aquí entonces supongamos que tenemos
unas de luz entrando por aquí con alguna
intensidad
llamémosle intensidad luminosa y cero
una intensidad que ocurrirá cuando la
luz logré pasar a través de este
recipiente bueno un poco de salud será
absorbida algo de esa luz a ciertas
frecuencias será absorbida por las
moléculas que tenemos aquí adentro
entonces saldrá menos luz de este lado
especialmente la que se encuentra de las
frecuencias específicas que absorben
estas moléculas de aquí saldrá menos luz
llamémosle i1
en esta situación si hacemos incidir la
misma cantidad de luz que teníamos en mi
cero esta es una flecha
sin si diéramos la misma intensidad y
cero a esta otra celda la misma que está
qué pasaría bueno qué más luz a estas
frecuencias específicas será absorbida
mientras la luz viaja a través del
recipiente la luz su cara con más
moléculas porque aquí hay una
concentración más alta a esa luz que
salga de este recipiente con alta
concentración la llamaré y 2 será una
intensidad más baja que 1 espero que
tenga sentido para ustedes esta luz
imagínense los fotones de la luz solar
con más moléculas que acá
eran absorbidos y al final pasarán menos
fotones que acá porque esta solución no
está tan concentrada para el caso en el
que el recipiente fuera más grande
dibujaré otra celda
más grande si tenemos un recipiente dos
veces más grande y tiene la misma
concentración que la celda número dos
llamaremos a esta número tres tiene la
misma concentración que el número dos
trataré de dibujarlo lo más parecido
la misma concentración
y hacemos incidir un as de luz un poco
de luz en general se usa la mejor
frecuencia para facilitar la absorción
pero esta vez hacemos incidir la misma
luz y 0 y de este lado sale le
llamaremos y tres que creen que pasará
es la misma concentración que aquí pero
esta luz tiene que recorrer una longitud
mayor así que una vez más la luz chocara
con muchas moléculas y más fotones serán
absorbidos por lo que menos luz será
transmitida
entonces y 2 es menor que 10 y 3 es la
menor de todas y se observan aquí se
transmite muy poca luz aquí poca luz
pero aquí de las 3 es donde se transmite
más luz si pusiéramos nuestros ojos aquí
este es nuestro ojo con pestañas y todo
observaremos que esta luz sería la más
luminosa esta sería un poco débil y ésta
sería muy débil y es lógico porque si
solo disolvemos un poco de soluto la luz
puede pasar fácilmente pero si saturamos
la solución ya no es tan fácil lo mismo
ocurre si la celda es más grande y la
siguiente pregunta es esto de qué nos
sirve esta información es importante
porque al saber que tanta luz se
transmite según lo que haya aquí adentro
podemos darnos una idea de la
concentración de la solución y antes de
seguir bueno les enseñaré a un ejemplo
en el siguiente vídeo pero ahora me
gustaría definir algunos términos que
tienen que ver con medir la
concentración de esto o la cantidad de
luz transmitida según lo que haya aquí
lo primero que definir es
transmiten cya
trans
militancia
muchos la definen como la magnitud que
expresa la cantidad de luz transmitida
según que tanto atravesó entonces a la
transmitancia la vamos a definir como
una relación de la cantidad de luz que
atravesó en este ejemplo es 1
entre la cantidad de luz que se hizo
incidir y ser
aquí la transmitancia sería la cantidad
que salió y 2 entre la cantidad que
entro
y 0
y como podemos ver este será un número
más pequeño y todos es más bajo que uno
así que esto tendrá una transmitancia
más baja que el número 1 llamémosla está
transmitancia 2 y esta transmitancia 1
la transmitancia 3 es la luz transmitida
la luz que atravesó la celda
sobre la luz que se hizo incidir y este
es el valor más pequeño luego sería este
y luego este entonces éste tendrá la
transmitancia más baja es el más opaco
seguido por este y luego este otra
definición que en realidad es más del
tipo de cosas que no se calcula sino que
se miden y tiene que ver con la
transmitancia es la absorban ya aquí
estamos tratando de medir qué tanto se
absorbe al calcular que tanto se
transmite un número grande significa que
se transmite gran parte pero la absorban
cya es todo lo contrario que tanto creen
que se absorbe si se transmite mucho
bueno pues se absorbe poco porque no hay
mucho para absorber y por el contrario
si se absorbe mucho significa que se
transmite poco entonces absorban 100
absorban cya absorbencia se define como
el menos logaritmo de la transmitancia
este logaritmo es base 10
o también
es igual a menos logaritmo de la luz que
se transmite de la luz transmitida entre
la luz que entra la que se hace incidir
entonces si la transmitancia es grande
la absorban cya será un número pequeño
lo cual tiene sentido porque si se
transmite una gran cantidad la absorban
cya será pequeña lo que significa que no
se absorbió mucho
este será un número grande otra cosa
interesante relacionado con esto es la
ley de deer lambert la usaremos mucho en
el siguiente vídeo la ley
dt
lambert
no sé la historia de esta ley pero estoy
segura de que la creo a alguien llamado
beer al principio creía que se trataba
de alguien transmitiendo la luz a través
de cerveza por el significado de la
palabra pierde en inglés pero en
realidad la ley de piri lambert nos dice
que la absorban cya es proporcional a la
longitud que tiene que atravesar la luz
por la concentración de esa solución
generalmente se usa la concentración
molar otra forma de expresar esto es que
la absorbencia es igual a una constante
una épsilon minúscula que depende de la
solución o el soluto que se esté usando
y de la presión temperatura y todo eso
absorban cya es igual a una constante
por la longitud que atraviesa la luz por
la concentración
ésta es la concentración
y la razón de por qué esto es tan útil
es porque imagínense si ustedes tienen
una solución de concentración conocida
voy a dibujar un eje aquí este es el eje
de la concentración concentración molar
que va desde cero y luego no sé punto
1.2 punto 3 y así progresivamente y por
acá en el eje vertical tenemos la
absorban cya absorban si digamos que
tenemos una solución de concentración
conocida punto 1 molar m de molar y
medimos la absorban cya de esa solución
la absorban cya a esta baja
concentración resuelta del punto 25.25 y
después hacemos lo mismo con otra
solución punto 2 molar y resulta que
tiene una observancia de punto 5
punto 5 el punto queda aquí apuntó 5
0.5 0.25 y lo que esto nos dice es que
hay un comportamiento lineal así que
para cualquier concentración la absorban
cya quedará sobre la línea si se
acuerden de sus clases de álgebra esta
épsilon por la longitud representa la
pendiente de esa línea esta de aquí y
recordando lo que sabemos de álgebra
podemos deducir la ecuación de la línea
o simplemente pueden usar la gráfica ok
así que tenía dos concentraciones
conocidas y fui capaz de medir su
absorban cya y como ahora sé que el
comportamiento es lineal y por la ley de
vietnam ver si siguiéramos tomando
mediciones todas coincidirían con la
línea incluso podríamos hacer lo
contrario podríamos medir la absorban
cya de una concentración desconocida una
solución que analizamos y encontramos
una absorban ziadeh
digamos punto 4 0.4 la solución tiene
una absorban cya de 0.4 y al seguir con
la línea podemos predecir que la
concentración es esta equis cantidad o
también se puede calcular de forma
algebraica de las dos formas dará un
resultado cercano a 0.2 molar o un poco
menos haremos un ejemplo sobre eso en el
siguiente vídeo